something that he's doing is pushing
this biomarker out to where nobody's
ever been before and that's really cool
so hello and welcome to the Shiki
science show where in this video I spoke
with Aaron King Aaron's been involved in
various longevity projects for the last
10 to 15 years he has written overviews
of the network of longevity
organizations as well as giving an
overview of scientific Pathways to
better understand the aging process most
recently he has built this tool age rank
which enables us to visualize how
different B markers are changing with
age we discuss this some more in this
conversation so there's some basic
information that's missing for the field
of Aging research and one of those
things is that we don't have a list of
all the things that change with age if
you just want to know like what actually
changes with age and what doesn't change
with age uh it just doesn't exist so in
pursuit of that I built this system um I
call it age rank but it's just a
biomarker visualization system and and
it um up as a search bar at the top and
uh you can take a look at any of these
biomarkers this is all enhan data for
now uh from the Center for Disease
Control they did this national health
and nutrition examination survey um I
think that's what it's called and hannes
is the short hand for it and so they
have all these biomarkers that they
measured about a 100,000 people over the
course of like 20 years bunch of
different cohorts anyway uh you can take
a look at any biomarker and you can see
whether you know what what it looks like
over the lifetime um for cross-sectional
data so let's just take a few
here
uh like this and we go to
go so we can see like uh you know
alkaline phosphatase it changes rapidly
during development and then it kind of
flatlines for the rest of life so it
doesn't really change after you're done
with development um aspartate I mean a
transferase never changes over the
course of the life really um Alpha 1
acid glycoprotein seems like it starts
it's increasing um as people get older
there's a there's a cut off with the
data here so this
system the the reason why it looks the
way that it looks is because uh I've
seen everyone else's data
when it gets presented during these
conferences or um you know online and
it's just really bad uh the box and
whisker plots the line graphs they don't
capture what's actually happening um and
a lot of times when they present people
present data they present it that way
because they don't they know that they
don't have enough data to really like
accurately show the conclusions that
they're coming up with so they're trying
to hide the fact that they don't have
strong data and that's why they use
these weird displays so I really like
scatter
plot um and this this red and the black
dots here are the um floating point mean
and median okay and uh you can tell a
lot of stuff I'm going to stop here for
for just a second and ask if you have
any any questions about what's going on
here or um something that might have
skipped
over yeah for sure so I mean firstly um
how long does this take you to make and
also are there any intrinsic limitations
with the current data set that you're
using uh it took a while it took
like I don't know it like a couple
months um the underlying philosophy took
like years to develop just like of
watching like all these different what's
going on in the field but the actual
data I would say that the code uh I got
some help with that um from an outside
Source um I actually hired somebody to
to rebuild the whole thing in in
JavaScript um
but the so the code is actually really
relatively simple the
data manually formatting enhs data took
a really long time and I did that myself
um and I would say that's the biggest
part of this is getting it the data into
a format that can be displayed easily in
a scatter plot that can be understood
easily by this
system uh because there's no you can't
script it so so if you go to the N
haanes website and you go look through
all their their data files from year to
year they change the naming systems they
change the organization sometimes a
biomarker will be in one category and
then it gets moved to another one and
then sometimes it's named one thing and
it's changes names and sometimes they
switch their methods so there's a lot of
kind of
like uh I
guess unique bi biology knowledge and
statistical knowledge that you need to
have in order to deal with the
underlying data set but once you can
format it which I did uh then it becomes
really easy to just to just visualize um
you were asking about
limitations so all of this is
cross-sectional data and there are
specific situations where it might be
the case that cross-sectional data shows
one thing and longitudinal data shows
another thing right um so as soon as I
can get longitudinal data into the
system to compare against the
cross-sectional data then we can see
like what the differences might be and
it shouldn't be that difficult but um
you know currently like I'm I appli to
get access to the Baltimore lunit
tudinal
study uh we'll see how that goes um but
there's other there's other there I
think there's a lot of cross or
longitudinal data that can be put into
this relatively easily it just takes
time I guess to to get access to a lot
of stuff and haes is free um or it's
it's public uh so it's it's the easiest
data set to
access interesting because I mean
obviously this has taken it looks like
this has taken ages to generate and put
it together um obviously this is an
incredibly useful resource that you've
built and so um I guess yeah the
question is what do you see as the use
case for this and what interesting
findings have you already observed so in
terms of gender specific differences um
alanine trans aminase is pretty
interesting uh you know the the sex
hormones and all that kind of stuff it's
very obvious that those are show gender
differences but if we look at um alanine
you can see if we go to mail and the the
demographic tools are over on the left
hand side here and so you can just go to
male you can see this this really huge
Arc and then when you go to
female uh all of a sudden that Arc just
kind of disappears um it's much less of
a change over time
and we can look at different years of En
haanes data and we can see the same
Trend this is important that being able
to to swap out plot sources I think is
really important um being able to swap
out medical ranges um is really
important we can you can change like
look at different um medical
institutions like Optimal range for all
these things anyway um so again here's
the female for 2017 data here's mail
right and so we can see oh you know if
you're like when you when we when we try
to uh change these things when we try to
figure out like what what things are
part of aging for who
um sorry let me back up uh if we know
that for females it doesn't change and
for males it does
change then we we actually know
like right now we have an example of a
mechanism for how like what is going on
in women that allows this to be the same
over the course of their entire life we
can actually look at this and study it
and then just and observe and say hey we
know how to do it now might not be
tenable like it might be tied into basic
biological functions um and so it might
be like oh well we just can't change
that right now but we do know it's
possible it's possible for a human being
to keep their alanine TransAm
pretty much the same over the course of
their entire life um let's see if
there's any other interesting for the
other male female iming only uh oh this
was interesting um total bone mineral
content let's go back to this and go
to dexa
scans uh total bone mineral
content um okay so here's
female and and
then mail
data what did that look
like Ah that's okay yeah so you can see
that for the mail data it stays more
constant and then for the female
data it has this
drop um at after age 50 which if anybody
can guess what happens at age 50 40 to
50 for
females uh it's very obvious menopause
related um potentially
so this is the kind of stuff and we can
take a look at all these these pieces we
can get a list of everything that really
changes with age and then that allows us
to understand okay here's what aging is
and and then what you can do is you can
take all these interventions that people
are doing on on you know for trying to
get anti-aging to work and you test it
against the whole list rather than just
like a few
biomarkers um right now most
people I would say that pretty much
every longevity Clinic what they do for
you is they tell you to not be fat don't
smoke and get an MRI and that's
essentially what longevity clinics do um
they don't have a list of all the things
that change with age so they can't
actually like measure the totality of
Aging um for
anyone um anyway that's what this system
was supposed to one of the things that
this system was supposed to
solve now the site slow and that's
because of that's on the site's end
because I'm hosting it on um not the
most expensive uh host but uh hopefully
I can transfer it to a more faster um
backend host and then it'll be better
okay so this is high sensitivity C
reactor of protein and I see it
mentioned a lot by various um aging
organizations or or Labs or clinics and
we can see that it has this like you
know it starts to go up with age but if
we take away everyone with greater than
BMI and we take a look at the
data
magically it's it's gone right like the
Aging has disappeared right so so these
black dots are median um and maybe I
should have explained this before but uh
the average for all these it really it's
it doesn't matter what the average is
because what you can get is pathological
subgroups uh subpopulations that will
pull the average up um even though for
most people a biomarker is staying
relatively flat and so the median is
really what we're interested in because
everybody ages um and perhaps I should
have said this sooner too that there's
two tenants that are kind of guiding
this whole thing which is one is that
everybody ages and two anything that
changes with age is part of
aging so that guides us towards um
finding out what this median curve looks
like for all these different
biomarkers because if the median like
whatever the median is doing that's what
that's what we're really concerned about
as far as aging is is concerned um the
averages again so like we you can see it
where when the red gets pulled away from
the black it it's a sign that um there's
a pathological subgroup that's
artificially pulling up that biomarker
curve
uh and if we can eliminate that and get
that red to be on top of the black then
it becomes a really strong uh much I
guess more true
um uh state of things um the last one
I'm going to show show uh share here is
scattin C which is a very
resilient
biomarker uh doesn't seem to respond to
BMI doesn't seem to respond to like
wealth level or gender everything that
you do to
this just the the curve looks exactly
the same where it just Rises with age
and then eventually it goes out of
bounds and your kidneys
fail so these this type of biomarker is
like a really
strong like this is what this is like a
core part of aging um other
biomarkers they can actually be solved
by just not being
fat uh I think I've I'm starting to
repeat myself here so I'm going to stop
here and ask some if you have any other
questions or or comments at this point
of course I mean so fly just as you
mentioned the CTO sattin C is was this
already known as a well established
biomarker um and obviously this has been
proven by your plots okay okay um and so
obviously this is really good data set
and I love it because it's gives the
attention to specific uh individual
markets because I think what got me uh
focused on the age uh this age rank that
you've created was you made a post on
LinkedIn saying that biological ages are
unnecessary and I think that's kind of
uh possibly a bit controversial given
like how the field is at the moment and
so therefore I'm wondering what are your
views on this concept of biological age
what we youve to yeah just shed
me yeah so
uh so the theory is it makes a lot of
sense right like there's this there's a
the biological age concept is like oh
chronologically I'm one age but my body
is in a different state and people the
the they accumulate damage at different
rates and they have different rates of
regeneration um and so you might find
one person at age 40 that seems
biologically very similar to this other
person who's at age 30 and so the
concept at a high level makes a lot of
sense but when you put it into practice
you get a bunch of biomarkers you
combine this is not for the methylation
bi biological ages is for the biomarker
a aggregation biological ages they get a
bunch of biomarkers they put them
together they come up with this this
weighted average and they say you're
this age and then you go great so how do
I fix my age to bring it lower and they
go oh well okay we'll split it back into
its core components find the thing
that's the worst and then Target that
thing with an
intervention well then why are we
combining it together in the first place
why don't we skip that whole first step
and just go straight to the individual
biomarkers and just you can tell me
which one's bad and then we'll go like
there's it's a completely unnecessary
Step at at the clinic level because you
can't interact with biological age to
any degree there's no therapy that
simply targets biological age it has to
Target a specific bi something that's
specific measurable thing and I've been
in the back room for some of these
clinics and the way that many of them
come up with biological agees they kind
of just have people sitting in a room
and they go you feeling what I'm
feeling that sounds about right and they
have like these weights that they just
kind of arbitrarily come up with um and
that's why they're all different from
each other that's why some of them are
are just very far off from what your
real biological age is is because it's
kind of it's just kind of based on feel
um and just sort of arbitrary waiting
systems uh so that part of it the
concept is a a good concept is just it
doesn't have any practical use at this
point um the way that people are are
doing it right now and if you think
about it what they're really doing is
they're they're trying to get a bunch of
biomarkers combine them together and
give you a percent Health rating like a
like if you're in a video game and
you're 78% healthy right that's
essentially what this number is no
doctor on the planet has ever done this
for anybody in the history of medicine
um it would have been really nice to
have in medicine to to go in the doctor
and the doctor tells you you're 80%
healthy that'd be cool to know kind of
uh but nobody does it that way because
it's a really useless tool like go oh
I'm 80% healthy what do I do about that
well well then they'd have to find the
thing that's making you not healthy and
Target that so so it's just it just
doesn't make a lot of sense um in
general yeah that's way describing it um
I I know as well that you've taken a
look at uh so like Brian Johnson's been
uh very open with all of the data that
he's collected what did you find from
looking at that data
set it was kind of it was interesting
because I'm back and forth like so I
don't like what he's doing I'm just I
look at what he's doing and sometimes
I'm just rolling my eyes like ohh this
guy but he I went through all of his
data and I found out that most of his
biomarkers are either like dead center
at the median of human population or
they're at like s of like the edge of
1% um and so he for for every single one
of his biomarkers except for one he's
gone to a place where people have
already been and those people didn't
spend $2 million to get there they just
you know per year they didn't spend that
money to get there he's he hasn't really
broken out except for Red Cell
distribution with where if we look at
his data it falls like far outside of
the scatter plot distribution that n
Hanes has at least um I don't know if
for any other biomarker data Bas is but
at least for enh Hanes he is far outside
the distribution and he's lower on the
lower end Red Cell dist width Rises with
age so the lower that you are logically
it just makes sense that it's
better and I was thinking about this and
at first I was thinking well he's only
got one biomarker but then I thought
he's got one biomarker like that's
actually a really huge achievement uh
being able to break out
of like you know that that the
distribution and go to a place where it
looks like nobody's ever been before
that's pretty big um so I think I I I'd
like to validate that like I don't know
if like how well it's measured and stuff
like that there's all sorts of like
things that could have been wrong with
it up leading up to him putting it up on
his website but if it's true then it is
a big deal it's actually a pretty big
deal because that means that you can
actually take these biomarkers that um
we see these distributions for he if he
can get outside of the bounds of what
everyone else is doing then something in
his his
whole uh I guess routine um some of it
is seems Superfluous but something in
there is clearly doing is clearly
working something that he's doing is
pushing this biomarker out to where
nobody's ever been before and that's
really cool
exactly and I think well this kind of
leads on to my next question which is
what is the sort of idealistic solution
to how we could go about looking at
people's age and how we can treat it
because obviously measuring so many B
markers is there's a lot of work to take
all those measurements from an
individual or um so I guess what's the
solution are you trying to find what are
the most effective bu markers that we
should look at and sort of reduce that
list to a smaller subsite or then we
eliminating information that's actually
quite insightful
yeah um you know people want to have
this this short list this like best list
and I think that's it's possible to get
there for me the the first step is let's
get a list of everything that changes
with age and some of them will be tied
together so um one biomarker like other
biomarkers might be stacked on top of
like one core biomarker and then if you
just measure that one you'll get this
other 30 you'll know the state of these
other 30 and that's really good if it if
it works out that way then
fantastic um if it
doesn't it'd be nice to know how
expensive it really is to measure
everything that changes with age um and
to to get to that point which is kind of
like the next phase of this whole
operation which is to figure out once
once I get a full list of everything
that changes with age then we can figure
out okay how expensive is it to measure
these things how accurate are all these
tests some of them have a lot of natural
variants um and so like how close are we
to even measuring them correctly and all
that kind of stuff
um I think that I think that the pursuit
of a short list right now is
premature but then again I'm not um in
with the uh the the Nia or the NIH right
now so I maybe they have better
information about this than I do but I I
just think that is premature at this
point to try to get a short list yeah no
I mean at least based on what you just
sh me it kind of makes sense that yeah
we're still very far from fully
understanding what's happening and so
it's too uh too soon to jump to
conclusions um and so this kind of leads
me on to the fact that um should be find
some interesting uh data points or buy
markers that inform us about the aging
process um I want to ask your opinion on
uh your current thoughts on whether or
not we can ref fast aging or how you see
us slowing down the aging process is it
possible um
so I've had a lot of different plans
over the
years uh at first it was about like is
all about um germ line biology which I
still think is the root of of aging and
why we're even mortal in the first place
um I still think curing menopause and
andropause and going down that road is
the the best pathway at this point
but uh you know replacement is getting
there's making Headway there um on
different replacement strategies so
that's really cool uh I could see that
happening I mean relatively quickly once
certain core components are figured out
my own plan at this point is um it's
kind of like a four-step process number
one
how do we can we just see what's going
on accurately and that's why this whole
I built this whole system and then two
is okay I'm gonna get from one side of
this curve to another side of this curve
where people already exist and that's
natural variants both of these steps
have kind of already been done to a
certain extent and so they're really
they're pretty conservative and I think
that they can be done relatively easily
we can get through those the third and
the fourth step the third step is can we
break out of the curve which is is again
what Brian Johnson did with that one
biomarker um Red Cell distribution with
and then finally can we turn those
curves into flat lines I have no idea
how long it's going to take but I do
know that the process for doing that
like each of those steps feeds into each
other and so I think that we can
actually go through every single one of
these things and find out how to take
this system that changes over time and
figure out how to like Flatline them uh
on indiv individual basis I don't know
if it's possible to do that with
everything but the the core concept
seems sound to at this point and I've
been talking to a lot of people and I
don't think anyone has tried it to do
this correctly in the past um
so that's that's my plan I think that
there's definitely like we see examples
of non-aging organisms and aging cells
all the time in the wild so Nature has
already figured out how to do this it's
actually pretty trivial for things to
just sort of exist
forever uh we are the weird things like
what we like like multicellular sematic
organisms that um get created and and
die with with the express purpose of
just getting sort of like used up and
destroyed and then um
discarded that's the weird thing in
nature like
the majority of what nature is is
single- cell organisms that are capable
of
um
maintaining uh What's the phrase again
um physical continuity
indefinitely and it just it's it's
really aggravating because um there
that's like that's like the game of life
that's getting played at at a sort of
like a fundamental level is that most of
the life on this planet by mass and by
by weight or by mass and by population
most of the life on this planet is
capable of being
Immortal we aren't because we're like
these vehicles that these single cell
organisms have built around themselves
and gone like to enormous complexity
over time over millions and millions of
years um but we are the we are the weird
things and and the normal game of life
is trying to stay alive forever like
that's what life is actually doing
and it would be really nice if we could
participate in that as well rather than
just sort of being vehicles that they
use in their game so um Nature has
figured this out and it'd be really
great if we could copy nature we've done
so in the past we've done it pretty well
we've we've gone we can build machines
that go underwater longer than any
living organism can any Mel anyway um
we've built flying machines
that can go higher than any creature
that exists that can fly uh I think that
it's it's very possible for us to to
figure out the nature of how these cells
are living indefinitely and then figure
out how to build technology to allow us
to to get at least to some extent you
know massively extended lifespans a lot
of these points that you've just
mentioned you summarize very nicely in
this sort of paper that you put together
I can share with my audience the theory
of biological mortality I'll share it um
and I liked one of the sentence which
was we are not the a organism the jam
liners and would you be able to
elaborate on your knowledge around like
reproductive biology and what you really
mean by this
concept yeah
so uh like when when we walk around and
we think what is life we we are
interacting with other you know
multicellular organisms and that's for
us like we we think like we look at a
beaver or something or like a or like a
giraffe and we think oh that's the
organism like this giant thing that's
what the organism is but actually it's
like it's like the world is full of
these like Mecca Walkers or whatever and
the these little Pilots inside which is
the germ line cells and we are the the
Walkers right we're these giant robots
that they build around themselves and
then they just leave it and then they
build a new version and they just keep
doing this over and over again
um and so uh there's some there's some
philos philosophy in there about the
nature of cell division and physical
continuity and identity um that I I
won't get into but um suffice to say
that uh there's there's some people that
believe that like if a germ cell divides
then it essentially dies I don't have
that view if it as long as it maintains
physical continuity then it's still
alive and if you take this view on life
then you look around it's like the
germline cells are the actual life forms
here like that's the actual organism and
so really the division is like the egg
and everything that's not the egg that's
that's the division between um germline
versus Soma uh that and that came out of
trying to reconcile because I was
looking
um I had this Theory a while ago of like
oh yeah there's germline cells and then
there's like the Soma around it but I
was think like male germ line and female
germ line because that's I mean
classical biology is like okay there's a
male germ line there's a female germ
line these are and then there's the male
Soma and the female Soma but if you look
at the rate of Aging for the egg versus
the female Soma it's different it's a
different relationship than the male
germ line and the male Soma and
um
actually Aubrey mentioned this to me uh
during this conference in uh Dublin and
I was like yeah like you know it that is
true and I was trying to reconcile that
and I was trying to think about like why
like how why are the rates of Aging
different for the the male germ line the
female germ line and then one day I was
just like what if the male germ line
isn't actually you know the The Germ
line what if it's just there's the egg
and then everything that's not the egg
and now the the female Soma the male
Soma the male germ line all fall in the
same category they're all over here and
then the egg is over
here and if you look at every single
organism through that lens suddenly all
these things start to make sense like
why like the construction of all these
different organisms and why they're
built the way they are it just makes a
lot more sense of from like a from an
engineering perspective like a like a
colony of ants is just you know it's
like uh if your arm could walk down the
street and grab food and come back
that's what an ant colony is the
everything that's not the egg inside of
that Queen is just part of this body and
the the the fact that it can communicate
across space through pheromone
interactions is just a feature of this
extended body so like an an Colony they
call it like a super organism no no no
it's just an organism that has physical
space between the components so like if
your cells could all dissociate and and
move around and then come back and
reform that's what an colony is and so
there the structure like the way that
all this evolutionary Pathways just
everything just makes a lot more sense
when you look at it through that lens so
that's why that's why I believe that now
I think that the The Germ line is
actually like that's the life form and
so if we can figure out how it maintains
itself
indefinitely um I think that's that's
where we're going to find our
answers uh in terms of multicellular
organisms planarians are very
interesting
um the hydras I don't know not so much
it seems like we kind of figure out how
hydras work but with
planarians um it's like a germline
colony and I don't know of any I don't
know of many other organisms that
operate like that where it's like rather
than your like in a human The Germ
Line's on one
location whereas in a planarian The Germ
line is kind of like spread throughout
the body that's why you can chop it up
and every single piece regrows a whole
new planarian cuz it's kind of like a
bunch of germ lines sort of hanging out
in this sort of collective mechanism
situation and that's very different um
from an evolutionary perspective than
like most life on this planet um so I
think that studying planarians is is
going to be really useful um and I wish
I could do all of this stuff uh but you
know time is of the essence so I think
I've we've gone on about that uh for a
while
there was something else that could have
been covered um oh that that Tory stuff
that's that's not as relevant at this
point um
so when I a few years ago I built this
massive overview of the whole longevity
field and then that led into a project
for the fora Institute for Building
their Tech this sort of Tech Tree
structure for trying to figure out the
organization of
um all these different Pathways and how
far we're getting on any one particular
pathway towards figuring out how to
solve aging and it was very good
personally because I could see what all
the bottlenecks were as as far as
descriptive tool I think it's just very
complex and so it was hard to interact
with and a lot of people just couldn't
you know didn't figure out how to
interact with it and know that's fine
but one of the things that came out of
that was that across the board I looked
at every single one of these fields and
I saw that Diagnostics were terrible
like it wasn't just a few it was like
like across the entire longevity field
Diagnostics were just bad for everything
and that's one of the reasons why I
built this AG rank system was because
it's like hey we don't even know what
normal aging even looks like for most of
these things how are we going to try to
intervene if we can't even compare it to
anything right um so that's so I thought
it was incredibly useful for myself um I
think it was hard for people to interact
with and and
ultimately um it's kind of been like
whay um so yeah we'll see I mean it's
it's just really complicated stuff
so difficult for sure yeah I mean if
anything it's been great to see that you
have still used it though to to build
this age rank system which I think is
going to have even more value uh to the
field so and that there definitely was a
purpose and there has been a successful
outcome from it
um but what else I mean you mentioned
that you're working on many things at
the moment is age rank your fulltime
sort of focus at the moment or whatever
things are you looking
at
um let's
see I would say that a rank is like most
of in terms of the longevity stuff that
I'm doing it that's most of it
um is there anything else
um I'm helping foresight again they they
still want to try to get this Tech tree
thing um to work so I'm just helping out
with that um
and I'm open to other stuff but um I
think my time is getting more scarce
now and I and we there's a lot of just
like there's a lot of really cool next
features for this uh this diagnostic
system so uh as far as adren is
concerned you know there should be the
ability to uh like have different graphs
like overlaid on top of each other um I
need to get more databases involved uh I
need to get um like metat tags on these
biomarkers so if you want to say like oh
I want to see everything involved with
kidney that changes with age you should
be able to just pull it up instantly and
then you're like oh well I want to see
everything that's uh within only like
the last five years or something like of
that and you just be able to filter
these biomarkers down and find these
subsets and be like okay I want to see
every every biomarker that's been tested
against this particular drug you should
be able to do that it should be just
instant right so there's a lot of
features I think that are the next steps
for that um and it just kind of depends
on on you know resources and um how much
support I can get for for building this
thing out
yeah well I think for sure I there
should be I mean I'd love to see it
develop um and so uh just I guess more
of a wrapping up sort of question I've
read some of your uh pieces of writing
before obviously speaking you say love
to hear your insights and I'm just
curious to know why did you accumulate
all this knowledge like how did you go
about uh learning so much about these
different topics was it from Reading
textbooks or how yeah how did you build
up this intensive knowledge and insight
into longevity
sure okay
so the first thing I did was just read
like thousands of
papers um and that's not an off-handed
comment that was actually like it was
over thousands like so uh at some point
I just realized you know it's not
illegal to just start reading tons of
things from El uh science director you
know these these other publishing sites
so you just start reading all these
things and going down into these rabbit
holes um and try to like have some sort
of mental organization but then the next
layer of that is actually going out and
talking to these people directly because
there's tons of things that they'll
never put into these papers about like
oh you know when we were doing that
here's what actually happened and then
we had to write it this way but like
actually here's and so you get that
level of insight and then you have to go
around and and find out talk to all the
people that are sort of into the this
so-called industry um which is I don't
think it's an industry yet or it
shouldn't be but you you talk to all
these people and you find out like why
they're doing it and what you know what
information um they have um and I guess
build up connections to people find out
like
it's at this stage of it there's so many
people that are doing it for money
rather than to try to actually solve the
problem
that a lot of it is about fil filtering
it's about like okay is this person just
trying to push their agenda or are they
actually trying to get something going
here um and so that's been the most
important thing for me uh at this stage
is
like how do you trying to figure out who
seems like they're really doing
something real versus just trying to
make a buck yeah yeah I agree um and so
I mean why do you think then there
should be more Focus obviously I'd agree
that reproductive biology understanding
the oversite Aging is definitely
something that we need to research more
but are there any other topics that you
would like to see more work
into
um let's see hibernation is very
interesting um so again I I'll I'll I I
don't mind saying this I'll say this as
many times as I need to reproductive
aging is obviously numbered one but
apart from that uh I like what fauna bio
is doing their whole angle on it um as
far as being a company I'm not sure how
legitimate they are but they seem they
seem pretty real to me the concept of
going after hibernation mechanisms in
mammals understanding them
deconstructing them and trying to
rebuild them in humans is seems like a
really good idea
uh and it's also one of those ideas that
doesn't overlap a lot with other
people's uh Concepts so they're kind of
in a very unique position and I like
what they're doing
um the organ construction you know organ
Printing and and organ replacement
that's always like really important I
think external organs is a field that is
like people don't think about it but
once we can put once we can build an
organ there's nothing from stopping you
from like making a second pancreas or a
second thymus and then just attaching it
to yourself like like sometime like a
hybrid like a it once we get stable
SEPTA to work and that kind of stuff we
can just like add organs that and then
we can design organs that have never
existed so that whole organ construction
field um Can can sort of blow up in ways
that people aren't really even imagining
at this point in time um so that's
another piece and I think that's those
are like the other two like
leading um fields that I think are
undervalued at this
point yeah for sure so well Aon it's
been great talking to you I mean it's
just amazing your insights I love the
way that you describe things and your
writing's been epic and it's just I
could only wish you the B of luck of
building AG rank father and hopefully
see many people use it um
and yeah I just it's been great having
this chance to talk to you and I
appreciate you taking the time out of
your busy schedule to do this so um yeah
thank you yeah no problem thanks for
having me um you know I I like your your
videos and uh what you're doing and I
hope that when you finish your PhD then
you uh are able to really make a huge
impact on the field um in terms of like
you know even more than you already are
so I hope say I think as well thank you
and I agree with your point I think yeah
talking to people and um hearing from
them in person their thoughts is almost
as valuable as reading like papers which
I know are somewhat skewed or like they
fit the narrative that people want to
see so I'm 100% in agreement with that
so yeah no thank you for coming on it's
just been great
fun all right take care and uh I'll see
you in the
future